hey everybody this is funded you don't
look so good
maybe you supportive of the volunteer
but I was a little Australian to ignore
me okay hey boys hey boys it's me ross
from game grumps how what's your
favorite episode boys god damn it Ross
tomorrow city to get a little
right god alright you failed god damnit
Ross damn cocktail Ross hi boys my
name's Ross from ok more names Joyce I'm
from spice Australia just Broncos Oh God
how's it goin bris my name is appear and
I'm from Sweden that's ending just can
never loses cool for any reason
I'm totally how awesome in every way cuz
some Canada I'm kidding baby oh yeah
cinnamon toast ken wants to go again ken
is turning into okay you think you know
what's best for cinnamon toast getting
those ten will do the double front flip
whether you like it or not well that was
pretty pathetic 10 for cinnamon toast
you take another view on it
cuz cinnamon toast can never quit
sending the dogs ken doesn't know when
to stop
okay Oh face of mine oh dang Oh governor
you want to buy a paper let's cut down
shoot Roy higher get more sleep boss
fighter queen that's a septic I ain't
afraid of nobody except silva markiplier
has no sense of style and is completely
tactless I'm so sorry hello ladies it's
me Danny sex bang couldn't help you
notice in my giant dog
well it's good of you to notice hi my
name is Erin Hanson otherwise known as
egoraptor how to do your voice David de
Bergerac
are you okay David de Bergerac boy yo
move ice does you boys appreciate his
level
alright the must assume across it's a
real tasteful tighter than my Veda storm
yummy my she's good at you for no such a
find um going on there very much
okay there goes oh god you're inside the
car Oh Oh that was not supposed to
happen oh the car pooped you out well
bum sorry to every single youtuber in
this video and that's ballsy I'm gonna
blow myself up as many times I get it
hate me alright so anyway that was more
turbo dismount check all the other
youtubers that we're in this video in
the description below they're all great
love them to death so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]
tell you what's next are these fun
[Music]
No